Speaker 1: So there's a segment from the Sean
Hannity Fox News program from the other day
that was meant to prop up this idea of Joe
Biden's not with it.
Joe Biden's having a cognitive issue.
Joe Biden can't think Joe Biden's brain is
imminently going to fall out of his head or
whatever the case may be.
And the clip is just stunning for its lack
of even like any self-awareness about the
fact that there were real questions about
Donald Trump's cognitive struggles throughout
his presidency.
So let's look at the first clip to begin with.
This is Sean Hannity and Kayleigh McEnany
saying, can you even imagine if there were
questions about, for example, Trump's cognitive
state?
And it's like there were do you not remember
Caylee?
Look at this.
Speaker 2: Can you imagine Caylee?
If this was Donald Trump's record or Donald
Trump was struggling cognitively like this,
what would it be like?
Speaker 4: I can't imagine.
I mean, look, I was at the podium when I was
asked over and over again about his trips
to Walter Reed, and they were routine visits
that he took, but they were convinced something
sinister, something must have been wrong with
the president.
He must have been covering something up.
Speaker 1: OK, so do you guys remember the
fact that Donald Trump was constantly acting
bizarrely and there were never any explanations
given and none of it made any sense, like
these folks seem to have missed Trump's entire
presidency?
Just a couple of examples.
I mean, just just just as a reminder, look
at a few things here.
Trump not only referring to the 1917 pandemic,
which didn't exist, that was 1918, but says
that it ended the Second World War, which
was, of course, more than a decade later
Speaker 5: in 1917, they say.
Right.
The the great the great pandemic certainly
was a terrible thing where they lost anywhere
from 50 to 100 million people, probably ended
the Second World War.
All the soldiers were sick.
It was a it was a terrible
Speaker 1: I guess he meant the First World
War and 1918, which it's not actually true
that the 1918 flu ended just completely confused.
And think if Joe Biden said that, what would
you be seeing on Fox News? Trump, of course,
talking about the oranges, the citrus fruit
of an investigation, really wanting to get
down to the rind of things we could say and
looking confused, realizing my my brain's
not connecting properly with my mouth here.
Speaker 5: They now go and take a look at
the orange.
Is the oranges of the investigation, the beginnings
of that investigation.
Speaker 1: That's weird.
That's weird.
And never an explanation.
And Cayley pretending like the only real questions
are about Joe Biden, the endless physical
shoulder spasms simultaneous to like a mental
catch on a word constantly happening regularly.
There were people seeking a medical explanation
for this.
Here's just one example of that.
Speaker 5: And let me begin by wishing you
a beautiful look here, remember this.
Speaker 2: You remember they were trying to
take Christmas.
Speaker 1: These sort of covers it in a way
where you don't necessarily pay more attention
to it unless you're aware of the fact that
that happens all the time.
Never an explanation for why that happened
regularly.
There was also this incident.
And I'll just we'll show some video.
As I describe it.
There's this strange incident where Donald
Trump came down off of Air Force One and his
vehicle parked right at the bottom of the
steps.
And Donald Trump famously just kind of wandering
off and having to be brought back.
His vehicle is always right there, Secret
Service, everybody waiting for him to get
in.
And Trump just wanders away and people start
wondering what what is happening here.
Eventually, someone comes up to Trump and
says, yeah, the car is right there.
The car was right at the bottom of the stairs,
like it always is every single time.
And Donald Trump brought back to that vehicle.
And we're not going to belabor this, but just
to remind you guys that, you know, Sean Hannity
and Kayleigh say imagine if Trump had done
the stuff Biden is doing.
Imagine what right wing media would have looked
like if Biden was doing half the stuff Trump
did.
They did an entire event about an executive
order and Trump left without signing it.
And then Mike Pence sort of like pretended
like the plan all along was to sign it in
private, even though they had a whole desk
set up for Trump to to sign it in public.
Remember this when you're trying
Speaker 2: to tell the Justice Department
to grant immunity to Michael Flynn, were you
trying to do that as president?
Is that your intention, Mr. President?
Sir.
Thank you, Mr. President.
Was that your intention when you're trying
to tell Trump
Speaker 1: just wandering away and then pens
reminding him you kind of didn't sign the
thing that we were here to sign?
And then just two last one very quickly, Trump
referring to Apple CEO Tim Cook as Tim Apple.
Speaker 5: We appreciate it very much.
Tim Apple,
Speaker 1: Tim Apple, and then also referring
to Marilyn Hewson, the CEO of Lockheed as
Maryland Lockheed.
Speaker 5: And we have some of our great business
leaders and leaders, period, right behind
me.
I may ask
Speaker 2: Maryland, Lockheed, the leading
the women's business executive.
Speaker 1: OK, so you guys get the point.
And so that's the real story here, is when
you see these segments on Fox News where they
say something like, imagine if Trump had ever
done the things Joe Biden has done.
And then you look at what Joe Biden has done
and it's like, oh, yeah, Joe Biden has a stutter
and he's nearly 80.
And he's clearly slowed down from like when
he ran circles around Paul Ryan.
However, many years ago, it was they said
Trump never had anything like this.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's quite the opposite.
And in fact, she and Hannity and everybody
else was running interference all along when
that was the case.
Just pathetic hypocrisy and double standards.